what's going on guys this is rob and i
really want to explore this idea of
shang chi the tin rings and kane the
conqueror having a connection to each
other and a lot of you guys were asking
in the previous video that i made why it
is that i'm so obsessed about this idea
of like kang and the rings and how it
all ties into shang chi here's a reason
for that based on the post-credits scene
we know that like shang chi will be part
of the new avengers right we know the
new avengers are coming but here's the
thing
based on what we know what's happening
and what we've seen happen in the mcu
whenever we as the audience think of an
avengers film any kind of an avengers
film we think of like the big show right
if the marvel cinematic universe was
wrestling avengers movies are
wrestlemania right like the big thing
and so whenever i think of something
like new avengers or something leading
up to it i think of like a big series of
events that culminates in this huge
calamity right this huge sequence of
things that are happening and we know
kane the conqueror is like the big guy
with spider-man and doctor strange too
it's very easy to kind of look at that
and get lost in this idea that like
there's the multiverse and there's
different things going on another
spider-man and so on and so forth but
that is by all standards of measurement
small-time stuff it's an interim event
to the bigger things that are taking
place the reality is the great big huge
next event right the next major villain
that we're aware of that is going to
have a kind of sequence of events that
center around them that are somewhat
equivalent to what we saw with thanos
and like the infinity gauntlet and all
that stuff it's came to conquer so i
think everything is all leading into
that and so what we're getting here i
think with like the ten rings and like
the eternals and doctor strange two the
multiverse of madness and like
spider-man 3 and so on and so forth that
it's all kind of like the equivalent of
seeing like captain america shield and
iron man and stuff like that right
thor's hammer landing in new mexico in a
post-credits scene it's on a much larger
scale but it's basically these small
little things that appear over the
course of movies that lead into like a
big event which is the king the
conqueror appearance and all the
different heroes fighting him so because
of that i think that what's going on
here with like shang chi is it's going
to give us like the whole new avengers
thing but i think it's also going to
lead into what is an effect avengers
forever now before i get into that
because it'll basically see the return
of like most likely tony stark chris
evans captain america things along those
lines let's kind of step back a little
bit and ask how do we get from like a to
b right how do we link these things
together now going back to our
discussion on the post-credits scene for
shang qi i still stick by the idea that
the rings were created by king the
conqueror now there are a lot of
theories out there saying the rings were
created by the eternals and there's
evidence for that right that we know
that like wong and them doctor strange
and as part of the whole sorcerer
supreme landscape they don't have any
knowledge of these rings or not in the
tombs but if these rings were developed
either by the eternals or by the
celestials for the eternals and the
eternals had basically walked away from
being involved in the affairs of
humanity in terms of guiding them they
stood hands off and just kind of
intermingled with society but
essentially erased all indication of
their existence then it would make sense
the rings would be erased as well right
they would just put them somewhere hide
them away and that would be it right
then they would just kind of go about it
and do their own thing and so if the
rings have been hidden away all this
time nobody would know that they exist
if you look at carol danvers and she
says there's no knowledge of these rings
across the universe that lends credence
to the eternals theory as well because
if the rings were created by the
celestials for the eternals or created
by the eternals themselves they wouldn't
exist anywhere in the universe they
would only exist on earth and in terms
of bruce banner saying i don't really
understand anything about these rings it
would make sense right the technology
that's possessed by these celestials
because i still stand by the idea that
the eternals are basically just going to
be super advanced robots but the kind of
technology the celestials would possess
just by virtue of being space gods would
be far and away beyond anything humanity
could possibly comprehend so it would
make sense if somebody like bruce banner
wouldn't fully understand it i don't
even think iron man would if anybody
were able to really understand what's
going on with these rings it would
likely be reid richards right he'd be
the guy they'd be able to figure it out
the intelligence of reed richards is
known throughout the universe right like
everyone knows how smart reed richards
is and probably the most respected mind
among everybody every race across the
entirety of the marvel universe even
cosmic entities like galactus realize
how intelligent reed is right so he'd
probably be the guy to be able to figure
it out but a lot of that stuff lends
credence to the idea that like it might
be eternal technology having said that i
don't really think it is it seems kind
of small beings to introduce something
like the 10 rings that could lead up to
something big and then say it was
developed by the eternals and it's just
a throwaway thing that happens we just
like learn about it in the eternals film
and it opens up and like the tin rings
are there they throw them in a cave they
leave and that's basically it it would
seem a little disappointing and kind of
a waste but it would also be pretty
simple right so that's possible having
said that i stick by the idea that the
rings were created by king the conqueror
now the question is how did they end up
in the modern era well i think the
answer to that question lies in the
purpose the rings serve so one of the
big things we kind of have to wrap our
head around here when it comes to the
mcu is that up to this point we've dealt
with what is in effect linear time right
five o'clock leads to six o'clock leads
to seven o'clock moves to eight o'clock
done right time moves in a forward
direction what we're talking about here
when it comes to somebody like kane the
conqueror it's the equivalent of you
throwing a baseball across a yard but
instead of it growing like forward
across the yard instead like that whole
yard represents time so like throwing
that baseball for kane the conqueror he
could throw it and the other side of the
yard is 5 000 years ago right that's how
cain the conqueror works when it comes
to time travel and so if these rings
were created by kane the conqueror and
they're emitting some kind of a beacon
which wong said they were presumably
across the entirety of the multiverse it
kind of makes sense right that's what
wong said like it's submitting a beacon
into the multiverse it's more
circumstantial that tells us that
because what we saw with like the whole
depiction was like the kind of
multiversal web that was shown at the
end of loki and so on is that it looks
like it's sending a beacon into the
multiverse then if it was created by
kang the most logical conclusion to draw
here is that marvel's basically going
with the map maker concept right so in
marvel comics when the multiverse was
collapsing what the map makers were
doing was something called riding
incursions right if you guys remember
our discussions on that the whole idea
behind this was that you had an
incursion taking place meaning that an
earth would just pop up and it was
basically universes crashing into each
other you would have an eight-hour
window between the time that you first
see that alternate earth until they make
contact right if both earths touch both
the universes are destroyed if one earth
is destroyed the universe has passed
through each other what the sedera
madris were doing as part of the agents
of the map makers is the sedera madris
were like reconnaissance guys right they
were field agents they were going out
and getting information and then
reporting back to the map makers and so
the way this would work out is that when
an incursion happened in some of these
instances the sadera madris would be on
an earth and so when the incursion took
place one of those earths would be a
dead husk and what the seder madrius
would do is they would quite literally
jump from that alternate earth onto the
new alternate earth and then they would
basically dislodge a chunk of that
destroyed earth and send it crashing
into the new earth and that would
basically give the map makers a place to
travel to right it was basically sending
out like a giant flare and saying this
is where we are and then the map makers
would follow that they would ride on
that new earth they would wipe out all
life and the process would begin again
but the reason they did that is that by
jumping from earth to earth they were
mapping the multiverse that's all they
were really doing right it was literally
just leaving a trail of breadcrumbs so
they'd always known where they had been
and they could trace everything that was
going on it makes sense that's what
would be happening with king the
conqueror with kane the conqueror having
returned at the end of loki one of the
things to contend with here is the
multiverse is a big place and if you're
the only king that's left the only one
there the multiverse does not
necessarily or may not necessarily have
come back exactly the way that it was
before the war of the kings and so you
kind of have to start over again you got
to map the whole thing if for no other
reason than to verify what you already
know but mapping the multiverse is a
difficult task so what better way to do
that than to create artifacts items that
you basically send out into the
multiverse and they just arrive on these
different earths but if kang sends them
into the multiverse and they arrive on
those earths they just arrive whenever
they arrive right i mean it's kind of
like we're just going to send it there
and maybe it arrives at 4000 bc maybe it
arrives in 5 000 years whatever the the
time period happens to be on that earth
when those rings show up they simply
just arrive there now the mandarin
likely stumbled across them realized he
could use them in his primitive
understanding of the rings like we
pointed out before and he just used them
to kind of conquer territories and make
himself powerful and they granted him
some level of immortality and that was
basically it but the whole time the
rings are sending out a beacon right as
soon as the mandarin got his hands on
him and basically activated them turned
them on they started sending out a
beacon and they were basically telling
kane the conqueror here is a world that
has not been conquered or here's a
universe that has not been destroyed or
here's what the universe looks like
whatever the case happens to be right
scanning the whole thing and just
sending that information back to kang so
he always knows what's going on in that
particular universe so if he decides to
conquer it he at least has some idea of
what to expect
that i think is the role the rings would
serve as they relate to king now having
said that that is a little complicated
but i think it also makes sense and it's
something they could build up with over
the course of the mcu by the time we get
to kang but if what we're looking to do
is tie into kang then this works because
then you start going into the idea of
avengers forever and that's where you
really get the whole role that kang i
think plays in the mcu that again
whenever we think of avengers movies we
think of like the big show right like
the big pop pop-off event like this is
where it's all been leading to
live on pay-per-view that's usually what
we think of when we think of like
avengers movies and so what better way
to bring in kang as like the big bad and
say this is a guy that exists out there
in the multiverse and this guy goes part
and parcel with time and then basically
have him face off against a whole bunch
of avengers teams from different points
in time that was avengers forever in
marvel comics right avengers forever was
a coming together of avengers teams from
the past the present and the future and
so what you get is like the original
avengers roster assuming that disney can
make good with scarlett johansson which
at this point i have no idea whether
that'll work or not so like basically
the avengers roster from the first
avengers film who in turn team up with
the new avengers who team up with
whatever the future avengers end up
looking like which would be cool because
it would basically be marvel telling us
this is what we're leading to right like
this is what the next next iteration or
the future of the avengers are going to
look like keep your eye out right i mean
it'd be it'd be cool to see that and
then like all three generations team up
they face off against kane the conqueror
and they win right they saved royal
credits i could definitely see that
happening with the with like kang as the
main villain for the mcu but again it
really all depends it just kind of
depends on what they're shooting for but
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section if you guys think
this is a ridiculous concept if you
think it's absolutely nonsensical if you
think it's entirely possible let me know
but thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace